all right [ __ ] it let's just click this
scooter video let's see this [ __ ]
enough with the [ __ ] dude hit me
with a scooter video speaking of
relationships bro speaking of
hold on hold on hold on this one is
gold in a way that you just you couldn't
oh
man this one
this one [ __ ] pounds
the tears on this one i know someone's
gonna give me [ __ ] for laughing at
at this dude's emotional state but you
can't not with the way this whole thing
plays out you can't
i couldn't even believe this was real
[Laughter]
like i thought jason sudeikis was gonna
be
the guy on the scooter with how
well-written this [ __ ] is hold on
okay this is unreal i'm trying and
switching the screen so uh everybody
could see it okay i can't wait
all right wait one more one more one
more sorry
and scene okay he's not gonna let me be
your friend
he's not gonna let him together and
there's no way it's gonna be able to
work
and you're gonna have to come to a point
where you're gonna choose him or me and
you're gonna choose him
you will because that's why everyone
does that will always happen
it's never me i'm never good enough
oh my god
oh my god
i love when someone's actions like
immediately validate what
they just said like this guy is like i'm
never gonna be good enough this is
always how it happens and then he
screams and rides away on a vespa
it's like dude maybe that's why
maybe that's the reason
oh my god dude oh my
god
his mother did not love him man oh my
god dude
so [ __ ] just the riding away on the
scooter
yeah it's so good i thought this was a
dax shepard movie or something
poor guy man bro it was it's just timed
so well and and to have that
man to have that argument
on like on a moped with a with a helmet
on
i just feel you you have such a lack of
respect for yourself
i would never be caught dead arguing
with someone sitting on a moped
you cannot no one will take you
seriously sitting on a moped getting
like you getting upset you can't have a
helmet on
it you can't do a hat you can have a
helmet on and do anything seriously
because it makes your head it makes you
look like a [ __ ] lollipop
yeah except for like a kick flip
or like a 900. you can have a helmet on
and do that seriously
yeah yeah but like like a skateboard
helmet like that
like extreme sport helmet no oh you're
yeah we're talking a motorcycle helmet
yeah motorcycle you cannot have a
motorcycle
helmet on and do anything seriously
besides dirt bike
[Laughter]
looking like the bottom half of a
snowman getting mad at someone like
please you can't leave me
she's like yes i can no she's like i'm
not i just think we should work on some
things he's like what
[Laughter]
i can't hear you i can't hear you
i never can hear you
it's how it always is whenever there's
[ __ ] helmet on
[Laughter]
god damn dude um
yeah i mean maybe maybe we laugh because
we're in america but maybe this is a
common thing
in like europe or like italy
you know arguing on a vespa yeah arguing
on a vessel and then just
driving off
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
also dude to like talk yourself to the
point of screaming
yeah like he talked himself up to that
yeah
like the the hysteria was growing
throughout the whole
the whole monologue and by the end he's
just had so much
[ __ ] in inside himself that he just
had to go ah
just to let it all out yeah now he i
mean that
that speech was not directed at her you
know what i mean
yeah yeah that was like for sure
directed at his mom or
something or
poor guy you know or the girl
or the girl's boyfriend that he was
gonna try to
oh wow
i'm sorry wow
i'm sorry now let's go to an ad
it's been 15 minutes so that's actually
going to be
that's perfect that's actually perfect
that was a perfect break right there
oh my god nate you better hit that
nate better hit that dude 15.52 and you
guys could check in
to see if he doesn't hit it new game if
nate misses it
um one guy has to dm his girl and be
like hey
nate [ __ ] it do you watch the ad be
for like blue chew or something
not satisfying your woman
[Laughter]
dude i was i was digging through old
notes
um because i needed to add some time for
my new video
and so i had the dumbest one but this
[ __ ]
had me chuckling a [ __ ] it was
basically like
a therapist be like vine okay
i said like just an inappropriate
therapist like he's like
so when you walked in on your wife what
exactly was she wearing
[Laughter]
that's like funny sneaking like
inappropriate ass questions
yeah that's great she's completely naked
whoa wow bae
and we're talking milkers or what
these mommy milkies or yeah the reason
why i'm asking this is because of the
freudian connection that you might have
with her big juicy milk wagons is that
the case here
it's even worse it's like so it's a
woman and he's like so when your husband
cheated on you who did he cheat on you
it's a young girl i couldn't believe it
she's like
she could be our daughter and he's like
oh that's disgusting
how old she's like 20.
geez barely legal what
no nothing it's just observation just
barely legal
so how did they meet
honestly i don't know but it just hurt
me
because we had the same hair color and
it just felt like he went like a younger
after a younger version of me ah yes
was she as well in doubt
what
oh that's funny how did they meet she
said some dating app was it hinge
[Laughter]
what's her at though that's her
you